Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two. David P.
The Egg Man called in and he
is completely shot out of a
cannon. Listen to this. Dave, you slayed
Speaker 2: that crazy Republican psycho lady
from Florida. But listen, when you were talking
about the death tax rate and the federal death
tax doesn't tax you, let's go over eleven point
one million. But states locally do know they want,
as she told you, that all of our clients that say
at least $250000 have to pay a bunch of money to
the state, you should just ask. Well, then do you
have a problem with the Santas ripping off all the
old people in Florida? Gov. Rick DeSantis a steal,
Speaker 1: Ron Ron, it's not Rick,
it's Ron. But I understand pulling
Speaker 2: money from all people in Florida,
and she's taking $3000 from each and every old
person to help them hide and steal their money
from the sand. The fact that the crooked shit.
Speaker 1: Whoa, whoa. Okay, yeah. So yes,
the Egg Man is correct, which is a lot of these
folks. So Florida actually doesn't have a state
estate tax that doesn't mean you don't pay
income tax depending on what's going on,
but that Florida doesn't have such such
a an estate tax, a state estate tax.
One of the things that should be mentioned is the
federal government gives you an eleven point seven
million dollars exemption on estate taxes. But
there are many states, including red states,
that don't that they do charge an estate tax. And
so there's a real question there about, Listen.
Biden's not taxing the estate. If you've got
five million, you don't get hit with a federal
estate tax. But in many states, including red
states, you do get hit with a state estate tax.
Why haven't these Republican governors fix
that? Why haven't they dealt with that? Because
I thought it was the Republican governors that
wanted to take away taxes. Lower your tax burden.
It's not actually going on. You can Google
state estate tax exemptions and you'll find
a lot of information about it. We have a great
bonus show for you today on today's bonus show.
Pat is out. I will be taking the reins of
the bonus show and we are going to talk about
what on earth am I doing in Las Vegas? Who have
I been seeing here? What happened on my flight?
What's going on with COVID? Am I getting COVID on
the trip? What's happening in Vegas? I'm going to
tell you about my wacky, delusional, outrageous
Lyft driver who was a COVID denying anti-mask.
Whack job. I mean, it's I don't even know what
else to call the guy, I'm going to tell you
all about it. On today's bonus show, sign up at
Join Packman dot com. You'll get instant access
to the bonus show. You can use the coupon
code. Wow. 22 to get a discount for yourself
if you're already a member and you want to do
something nice for someone else. What's that thing
from each according to their ability? I forget
the thing. But anyway, 630 viewers have asked
for a free membership. If you want to request
a free membership, you can fill out the form
at David Pakman dot com slash free membership.
630 people are waiting for free memberships.
You can start helping us chip away at that
by checking the box that says this is a gift.
When you sign up at join Pacman dot com and then
we'll give away that gift to somebody on that list
of six hundred and thirty people waiting. So do
it. We will see you on the bonus show and I will
be back with you tomorrow, as well as on the bonus
show. Normally, Pat does the Friday bonus show
this week he did Monday, Tuesday. I'm handling
Thursday, Friday. I'll see you then or tomorrow.